ariana grande may be thankful for her
exes but is she trying to erase the
memory of one of the guys she named
drops in the song tattoo cover-ups and
Twitter bombs
Ariana's thank you next is the gift that
keeps on giving and we're here for it's
over for it after the record-breaking
music video dropped she responded to a
fan in a sense and deleted tweet writing
actually I don't want no next true love
doesn't exist hope you're having a great
day hmm I would say this she followed up
tweeting true love might exist I was
just hungry but still after that okay I
related to that tweet I would tweet this
I would a hundred percent with us all
right here's the big question though is
hangry tweeting a thing or is Ari still
coping with heart being heartbroken I
think it's a little bit of both cuz I
definitely can hangry tweet if I'm a
little like if somebody says the wrong
thing to me pushes my buttons I'm hungry
I'm like clap back so has ariana grande
given up on love or will she bounce back
I say she'll bounce back and she was
hungry I think it's one of those things
too when you're like currently focused
on yourself in the moment you're like
this what I'm focusing on now but I
think deep down you know someday along
the road there's still some hope out
there yeah bus one love and as promised
Ari also released more behind the scenes
content of the thank you next video
including a deets on her Legally Blonde
inspired choreography Bennett's nap
which is the most iconic one of those
iconic dance but now it's brother thank
you next
and I come up with this guy but guys if
you look closely during our ease killer
thank you next choreography her foot ink
refills a big change was like what a
foot
taking my myrin guys
how cool right the tattoo used to read
841 for the badge number of her
ex-fiance Pete Davidson's firefighter
father who died on September 11th yeah
of course it's a really heartfelt tattoo
to get and now it reads Myron the name
of Mac Miller's dog he adopted in
January 2017 and of course we know this
is not the first time Ariana has covered
up a Pete Davidson inspired tattoo no
we're gonna run down the list we know
she used the band-aid during the wicked
performance of her finger tat and
replaced it with a large heart and she
also covered up a matching reborn tattoo
on her hand what looks like a feather or
a fern leaf now there was this big
debate of course we know this is not
confirmed on whether she's officially
adopted myron after Mac Miller's death
but we're assuming so yeah but it's our
E's latest tattoo coverup necessary give
us a thumbs-up thumbs-down et spoke to
music video director Hanna Lux Davis
about the making of Artie's video
including her burn book references they
are so good she's talking about people
she's dated in the past are you working
with her on are we gonna decide what to
write in the book together how did you
decide to kind of bring all that to life
from the jump on the video we didn't
want anything negative everything had to
be positive and like grateful and like
really what this song is about and so we
wanted to make sure that even in the
burn book it wasn't a burn book it was a
thank you next book she definitely like
made it personal to her and that's again
where I feel like everybody's connecting
with it and like they're like oh you
know cuz it's like it's very much it's
what she would write in her life in this
character so in true re nature of course
she didn't want to stir up a lot of
drama but I really loved a lot of her
burn burn book references she just takes
the high road where I would not and I
really respect her at least you're being
honest are you guys a fan of Ariana's
latest tattoo change and do you think
it's a direct link to Mac Miller and
what do you guys think about the
singer's deleted tweet do you see her
being open to dating again I see it I
see and I know she's going through some
heartbreak but she should take a beat
yeah and she was hangry of course you
want to keep this conversation going
across social I'm at Kourtney underscore
teza know and I'm at ash Carlson and
until next time we've got you covered